[Musik]
hi
bin Sakko angezogen richtig schick
gemacht darunter habe ich vielleicht
noch ein Schlafshirt an aber das
ignorieren und die fragt mich jetzt
wahrscheinlich Mensch loser Luca warum
hast du denn Sakko angezogen ziehe
irgendwie ein besonderen Anlass hasse
die Frau fürs Leben gefunden wirst du
heiraten nein wir schauen uns heute mal
Chat geht die Chat geht die Chat
wie heißt der Bums Chat GPT schauen wir
uns heute mal an als er von nichts
mitbekommen habt mein Beileid ihr lebt
hinterm Mond kurz zusammengefasst ist
Chat GPT quasi genauso wie der cleverbot
nur 2 Milliarden liegen krasser man kann
ihn nämlich nicht nur so Sachen fragen
wie es ihm geht oder was er gerade an
hat sondern man kann sich auch einfach
die
kernspalt-theorie Physik erklären lassen
ich weiß nicht ob das existiert wir
starten dennoch ganz entspannt mit hallo
wie geht es dir hallo mir geht es gut
danke der Nachfrage wie kann ich dir
helfen ich möchte gern wissen was du
heute gefrühstückt hast
schreibe ich einfach mal ich bin ein
Computerprogramm ich habe keine
Möglichkeit zu essen oder zu trinken ich
bin nur in der Lage die durch den
Austausch von Informationen zu helfen
gibt es etwas Spezifisches mit dem ich
dir behilflich sein kann
ich hätte gern zehn Millionen Abos auf
Youtube man muss ja klein anfangen er
antwortet es ist ein großes Ziel 10
Millionen Abonnenten auf YouTube zu
haben um dies zu erreichen gibt es
mehrere Schritte die du unternehmen
kannst hier sind einige Tipps erstelle
qualitativ
da scheitert schon versuche regelmäßig
neue Videos hochzuladen um deine
Abonnenten zu unterhalten und dazu zu
bringen wiederzukommen drittens nutze
soziale Medien verwende andere soziale
Medien um deine Videos zu teilen und
neue Zuschauer zu gewinnen antworte auf
Kommentare und Fragen dann dazu schauen
oh wie eine Beziehung
investiere in Werbung von der hey okay
ich habe kein Buch abonniert dir es ist
wichtig zu bedenken dass das Wachstum
deines Kanal Zeit und Geduld erfordert
halte deine Ziele realistisch und
arbeite hat daran deine Zielgruppe zu
erreichen und deine Inhalte zu
verbessern also grob zusammengefasst
soll man all die Dinge machen auf die
ich seit 11 Jahren Youtube komplett
scheiße wenn Chat GLP allerdings schon
sagt
GPT GLP bin ich dumm wir brauchen einen
Alarm für das Programm schreibt
irgendwas unten in die Kommentare wie
kommt man so ein Roboter nennen wenn
dieser Ulm hier allerdings schon sagt
dass wir das mit den 10 Millionen
Abonnenten wahrscheinlich nicht
erreichen werden weil wir die ganze
Sachen eh schon nicht erfüllen dann
würde ich sagen fragen wir ihn etwas
anderes wie werde ich Milliardär weil
Millionär bin ich ja schon längst
[Musik]
so wie ich diese antwortet jetzt schon
wieder direkt ey das ist wirklich krass
wie schnell der antwortet es gibt viele
Wege um ein Milliardär zu werden aber es
erfordert in der Regel viel harte Arbeit
Durchhaltevermögen und risikober
Bereitschaft einige Möglichkeit um
dieses Ziel zu erreichen können sein
Gründe einer erfolgreiches Unternehmen
viele Milliardäre haben wir vermögen
durch die Gründung und Führung
erfolgreicher Unternehmen gemacht
investieren Aktien Immobilien und andere
Vermögenswerte durch klug Investition
hey das ist krank dieser Website ne die
kann dir no joke auf alles ne
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kann dieser Wally hier theoretisch
Deutsch Hausaufgaben für ein erledigen
die kleine Tochter meiner Nachbarn kennt
mich und wurde letztens umgeschult und
hatten mir dann als Geschenk ihr
Schulbuch aus der 8 Klasse gegeben ich
weiß auch nicht warum
habe mich auf jeden Fall habe mich auf
jeden Fall eher
ich habe mich auf jeden Fall eher so
semi darüber gefreut auf jeden Fall
fängt man tatsächlich im
Deutschunterricht der achten Klasse in
Deutschland schon an mit gedichtsanalyse
das ist der größte Scheiß ich weiß dass
ihr das braucht und dass ihr aufpassen
müsst dafür die Klausuren aber danach
glaube ich bin 26 ich habe in meinem
ganzen Leben nie wieder ein Gedicht
analysieren müssen so oder so fragen wir
Chat GdW jetzt allerdings mal wie wird
das Göttliche von Goethe interpretiert
da bin ich mal gespannt ob er mir hier
weiterhelfen kann er schreibt schon das
Göttliche ist ein fragmentarischer Text
von Johann Wolfgang von Goethe der
niemals vollendet wurde und indem er
seine Gedanken über Religion Gott und
die Natur reflektiert es gibt viele
Interpretation dieses inter-in
gescheitert schon daran dass ich nicht
mehr die Antwort lesen kann also wir
haben verschiedene interpretations
Interpretation interpresentiert genau
wenn es diese Website gegeben hätte als
ich noch zur Schule gegangen wäre ne
ich hätte keine Hausaufgabe mehr selbst
gemacht no joke schickt dieses Video mal
eure Mitschülern in eure klassengruppen
rein keine Ahnung was oder diese Stelle
oder filmt das hat mir scheißegal ich
liebe euch wahrscheinlich stundenlange
Hausaufgaben für die Zukunft ab indem
ich euch diese Website hier gezeigt habe
nehmen wir jetzt allerdings mal eine
Aufgabe aus dem Matheunterricht und zwar
was genau besagt der Satz des Pyta
Vita
goras
seine Grenzen
[Musik]
nein der zeigt mir sogar nein das wird
so geschrieben
der erklärt erstmal was das überhaupt
ist dann schreibt er den hin dann
erklärt er die Formel und dann sagt er
noch was zur Geschichte
ihr müsst euch halt mal überlegen dass
genau das was diese Website schreibt
steht in diesen Worten nirgendwo anders
im Internet das heißt sie könnte es
ruhig eins zu eins abschreiben für eure
Mathe Hausaufgaben oder Deutsch oder
welches Fach auch immer und er geht
dabei auch noch mit einer perfekten
Rechtschreibung grammatikalischen
wortsetzung Komma Setzung mit allem
möglichen perfekt vor
und es gibt auch noch ein dark Mode aber
der ist hässlich ja also mittlerweile
herausgefunden dass Chat KaDeWe alle
möglichen Hausaufgaben Verein
beantworten kann er kann mir sagen wie
ich auf Youtube erfolgreich werde wie
ich Milliardär wäre aber was er noch
nicht beantwortet hat ist was die beste
merchandise Website der Welt ist super
was ist die beste merchandise Webseite
weltweit da kommt er wahrscheinlich auch
wieder ein bisschen an seine Grenzen
weil merchandise jetzt erstmal ein Wort
etwas englisches Plural da ist ja schon
wieder es gibt viele Webseite
merchandise verkaufen und welche am
besten ist hängt von der individuellen
Anforderungen Präferenzen das benutzt
das ab einige der größten und
bekanntesten Webseite für merchandise
weltweit sind Amazon
luca-shops eigentlich auf der Eins mit
den Umsätzen kennst du den luca-shop.de
ich bin Apple Computer
[Musik]
der kann mir nicht sagen ob es ein
luca-shop.de gibt oder nicht ist
laserluca der beste deutsche Youtuber
meine Damen und Herren das fragen wir
Chat Kiel irgendwas ich weiß auch nicht
ganz genau wir fragen uns auf jeden Fall
den Roboter ja auch mal und er antwortet
noch gar nichts
ist er jetzt sprachlos so lange hat er
noch nie gebraucht ist der ganze mal
eine Frage kannst einfach ja schreiben
ein Tag später hallo
komm jetzt mach
der kommt nicht klar dieses Programm ist
überall in den Medien und in den
Nachrichten zu sehen weil es angeblich
jede Frage beantworten kann weil die
Frage ob Laser Luca der beste deutsche
Youtuber ist das bringt ihn zum
Schwitzen so wie mich in diesem
hässlichen Zara Sakko was ich mir für 30
€ gerade gekauft habe
das war die LED-Lampe das ist eine
subjektive Frage und hängt von den
persönlichen Präferenz der Meinung jeder
der das ist überhaupt nicht subjektiv
der ist der beste Youtuber kommen an der
Stelle wo ich das heutige Videos
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
Freunde wenn ich euch mit dieser
Webseite eventuell für die Zukunft
einige Hausaufgaben Stunden abnehmen
kann dann abonniert meinen Kanal klickt
auf die Glocke weitere Videos nichts
verpassen und sendet dieses Video in
eure klassengruppe
Website ist unten in der
Videobeschreibung verlinkt also schaut
euch gerne mal vorbei und bringt immer
bei das Laser du keine beste Youtuber
ist das kann ja nicht sein